it being 10 o'clock I'm going to open
the public hearing criminal justice
today
I would ask that you rise and join us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
this time we're going to open the public
hearing on HP 89
and we're going to have representative
Muse introduce bill
thank you Mr chair my name is
representative David Muse I'm uh I
represent uh Portsmouth Newington and
Newcastle
um we have been in this place before
with this bill as the chair knows and
those of us who've served over the last
couple of terms
um and I I believe we're in a in a good
place now uh one of the things that our
assistant uh Brad Greenland did was he
uh uh researched some of the history of
the bill to provide to some of the new
members
um one of the things that you'll see is
in the last session of the legislature
we sent this bill to interim study and
the outcome of the interim study session
was that we did recommend it for
legislation which is why this the
primary reason why this bill is back
uh
but the overwhelming and I think the
driving reason why this bill is back is
to really uh do what we can as a
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee to when we
when we when we are aware of incidents
uh in of uh where Justice uh hasn't been
carried forth uh effectively and and
also when where there have been
injustices a lot of times we're not
necessarily in a position to correct
that
um uh this time though we are
um uh this bill specifically would Grant
a posthumous uh exoneration and
annulment in a couple of cases where
over time
um the Injustice of those convictions uh
has become more and more apparent
so one of these folks uh Eunice goodicol
of Hampton New Hampshire
was the only person in New Hampshire
ever convicted of witchcraft
uh in uh she one of the things that you
you can see if you actually Google
information on goody call was she led a
pretty tortured existence
um she probably wasn't a very nice
person her neighbors did not like her
but unfortunately at the time dislike
for a person could easily turn into
accusations of Witchcraft and there was
a hysteria that went on at the time and
at the time the law supported
convictions like that
spent a pretty good chunk of her of the
last 25 years of her life in prison
much of that time at the expense of the
people of Hampton New Hampshire
those people in Hampton New Hampshire or
their their descendants in 1938 actually
formed a group called The the goody coal
Society
and essentially what they did was they
uh they basically forgave her crimes
Unfortunately they don't didn't have the
power to forgive and all the crimes that
she was accused of we do have that we
are a state where witchcraft is no
longer a crime
um the other case is the case of Willard
upposts and I I have uh other folks here
who are going to give a testimony about
this uh but he was the head of the world
Fellowship Center
um and uh essentially to make a long
story short
um uh an overzealous New Hampshire
prosecutor during the Red Scare of the
1950s
held Mr up house in contempt brought him
up on contempt charges for not revealing
a list of of members and attendees
to programs at the world Fellowship
Center
which is primarily an organization
that's about uh nature and spirituality
and we have the former head of it here
today to testify to testify on that as
well
um the the the upshot of this of a lot
of this is is there are
periods when there are Injustice uh in
our past and in our current law really
doesn't allow a good mechanism for us to
address this so one of the things that's
been brought up in the past is well gee
why can't the governor just pardon these
people
and the reason the governor can't just
pardon these people is that the way that
our law works now uh is that the
governor can only pardon people who are
alive which is why we're talking about
um annulments and exonerations
um
so
to essentially sum up one of the things
that we have within our power to do
today is to correct an injustice that
was done a great Injustice that was
actually done to uh to two people who
you know who who didn't deserve it who
may have had issues in other areas
but this is not the way our justice
system our just the systems should work
and one of the things that are our
justice system uh should do when we
don't have the power to actually go back
and fix things is to make an admission
that sometimes we make the wrong
decision and uh and to do what we can to
to correct the record so that's really
why uh why we're here today
um
one of the other things that I would I
would like to do uh with the chairs
Indulgence is to read a testimony that
was sent to us uh by Arne Albert who was
not able uh to make it Arne testified at
hearings both times on the previous
bills he is out of town and unable to
join us in person today so with the
chairs Indulgence I would read that I
would also let the chair know that
this testimony was also sent in email to
the committee so if you decide in the
interest of time that that would work
better that's fine as well
um you can go ahead and read it into the
record
thank you
and if anybody has any questions about
the bill the legislation
um I I think we have folks who are maybe
better equipped to tell the story and to
really relate the history of what
actually happened during these events
than me but I would be more than happy
to answer your questions
yes
uh assuming this is a terrific bill in
correcting an injustice I have two
questions first uh why can't the
governor pardon someone who is not
living the second question is does the
legislature really have this Authority
there are questions our law currently as
I read it and I'm I'm not a lawyer but
my examination of the statute the pardon
statute really only does apply to people
who are living and these these two folks
obviously aren't living anymore as to
whether or not we have the ability to uh
to exonerate and in all convictions we
do and uh in the last session of the
legislature we actually uh we actually
did that in hb2 when we annulled the uh
and all the convictions of the folks who
violated uh uh covid orders uh at the at
the time so I don't think it's a it's a
power that we use a lot in the
legislature and I think we're very
careful about how we use it
um but uh it is something that there is
precedent for
you're welcome uh just for the in case
anyone else is going to ask I am going
to be soliciting an opinion from the
Attorney General's office and possibly
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
um I I personally actually wrote the the
majority report recommending this for
future legislation I still support the
idea behind it I just want to make sure
it's constitutionally sound
and I do know that in the past there has
been some uh confusion over where goody
Cole in particular was convicted
she was convicted in a court in
Massachusetts at the time the state of
New Hampshire and the state of
Massachusetts actually didn't exist what
existed back in her time in this in the
1650s was the province of New Hampshire
and uh
essentially New Hampshire was just sort
of a series of land grants stitched
together without any real type of a
judicial system so at the time we relied
on courts uh down in down in
Massachusetts she actually served most
of her jail time down in Boston but she
was a citizen of Hampton New Hampshire
which is part of New Hampshire now
so there are some gray areas you know
admittedly but
there are always gray areas in the law
and this may be an opportunity just to
correct something that I think a lot of
people over many years have been trying
to correct representative salic
says that the language needed to be
clarified from the initial version I'm
just wondering what if there are
differences in this language than
previous versions
I I think the it's less the language
issue and more the issue that uh that
the chair raises so there there is an
issue uh you know ultimately whether we
have the authority to actually
um uh exonerate and pardon somebody who
may not have been uh you know
technically who who actually may have
may have been convicted in a in a court
in another state
um even though at the time we were
basically in the same judicial uh
judicial region I guess you might call
it
so
okay you can go ahead and read that now
that you wanted to read you wanted to
read that testimony
would you like I can do that yeah go
ahead
so again this testimony is from uh from
Arnie Alpert
I regret that I'm unable to be with you
in person today to testify in support of
hb89 relative to posthumous exonerations
and annulments but I'm happy to respond
by email to any questions you may have
in 1951 the general court adopted the
subversive activities act which defined
and criminalized being a subversive two
years later the Attorney General Louis
Wyman launched a wide-ranging
investigation to find out where any
subversives might be lurking Wyman
looked high and he looked low among
among the places he looked were at UNH
and Dartmouth faculty he interviewed 130
Witnesses under oath and even more on an
informal basis
among those he subpoenaed for deposition
was Dr Willard uphaus who had recently
been appointed executive director of the
world Fellowship Center a summer Retreat
near Mount chakurua in Albany New
Hampshire
Dr uphouse went to Wyman's office at the
state house and brought him information
uh about world Fellowship when asked he
was willing to provide the Attorney
General with names of Staff
records for which the state are and with
with names of staff and and also for
records for which the state already had
access
he was also willing to provide the names
of people who had been speakers of the
center and even invited Wyman to be a
speaker
but Dr uppost blocked when attorney
general Wyman demanded the center's
guest list which he knew would subject
people to further investigation a
superior court judge ruled Dr uphouse in
contempt prompting an appeal that went
uh all the way up to the United States
Supreme Court when the Supreme Court
ruled six years later after the investor
after the investigation began on the
side of the state and Dr uphouse still
refused to violate the privacy of world
Fellowship guests the state sent the now
elderly doctor up house to the Merrimack
County House of Corrections uh where he
sat for a year
during the course of the year the up
house case became a matter of
international controversy and frankly a
source of embarrassment to the state
two points that I want to emphasize
first after an investigation that he
claimed took two and one half man years
Lewis Wyman never charged anyone in New
Hampshire with the crime of being a
subversive
second looking back with more than 60
years of hindsight we should see the
episode as an example of what happens
when political passions overcome good
judgment
we can also see Dr Willett up house as a
champion for the rights of conscience
and the protection of privacy from State
overreach
please recommend HB 89 ought to pass
Arnie Albert one mudget Hill Road
Canterbury New Hampshire
thank you
there being no further questions thank
you
who's next
thank you
chair calls Andy Davis
thank you good morning
um uh it's a pleasure to be here thanks
for hearing my testimony I'm also
um uh coming out in favor of this bill
I'll try not to go over the same
territory that David and Arnie covered
um my name is Andy Davis I um until uh
about a year ago for 21 years was the
co-director of the world Fellowship
Center uh the the second uh director
after Willard house who we're referring
to today
the world Fellowship was founded in 1941
by Charles in Eugenia Weller who at that
point were in their 70s they were social
activists and reformers who began in
Chicago in the um the first Gilded Age
in the 1890s but by 1953 the wellers
were in their 80s and they were ready to
retire from uh what was in this Essence
their retirement job so they cast about
and they ended up hiring much younger
directors people who were about my age
now Willard and Ola up house
and um by the time Willard came to World
Fellowship he had already seen many
lives and careers destroyed by
McCarthyism
he had suffered the effects itself to
organizations that he had been a part of
the national religion and labor
foundation and the American peace
Crusade had been ripped apart by
internal divisions or disbanded because
of the climate of fear that was
generated during that time
so at the end of their first summer as
directors Willard Nola were closing down
World Fellowship for the winter and
Willard took a break to go into Conway
and run some errands and he picked up a
copy of the union leader and uh was uh
uh his attention was caught by the main
headline that said Pro red takes over
New Hampshire Fellowship group and of
course the uh Pro red that was being
referred to was himself
um he read further to discover the news
that he supposedly supported the
Communist party and was harboring
members of subversive organizations that
was news to himself and uh in a sidebar
on the front page the Attorney General
Louis Wyman pledged to get down to what
was going on at the world Fellowship
Center
so this began seven years of
interrogations and Court appearances
that went through the New Hampshire
Superior Court in which as stated he was
convicted of contempt for refusing to
expose
guests of his Center to the sort of
scrutiny and ordeal that he was going
through and uh
the case went all the way did the U.S
Supreme Court I'm not sure that was
mentioned already but on November 14
1958 the U.S Supreme Court ruled five to
four that the public interest outweighed
up houses private rights given the power
granted Wyman by the legislature the
Attorney General could force up house to
produce the guest list or prosecute him
Justice William Brennan wrote the
dissent in which he was joined by the
Chief Justice and justices black and
Douglas he argued that the state had not
proved a sufficient interest to justify
counterbalancing the interest of privacy
as it relates to freedom of speech and
assembly
so as Arnie mentioned the Willard up
house case became a cause celebrity the
day that he was led away to jail 200
supporters were on hand to sing America
My Country Tis of Thee and A Mighty
Fortress Is Our God which was Willard's
favorite hymn and hundreds of college
students around New England demonstrated
for his release and
um on his 70th birthday which he
celebrated in the Bosque in jail he
received 720 cards from around the
country
well incarcerated up House Road is
autobiography under a painting of Mount
Chicora
and
um
in an effort to be brief I'll just uh
it might interest you to know that um
Willard up house was included on the
Concord Monitor list of the hundred most
influential people in New Hampshire
during the 20th century and um and in
case you're wondering Louis Wyman didn't
make the list
another person on the list was Judge
Hugh bounds of Laconia who served on the
New Hampshire Superior Court U.S
District Court and the U.S court of
appeals in the first circuit earlier in
this career he had been a defense
attorney in Willard House's case when he
died in December of 2003 at his memorial
service in the federal courthouse here
in Concord he was eulogized by his
friend Justice David souter who taking
stock of his long career specifically
referenced bound to spirited defense of
Willard house
Suter said that what stood out was
bounds's argument that the state had not
a scrap of evidence to so much as
suggest up house engaged in subversion
bounds Suter said was facing a quote
facing realities that the powers that be
did not want to face and did not want
others to face it was as if he knew
Sutra continued that human beings do not
so much avoid responsibility as evade it
and we evade what we do not want to see
bounds he said had the courage to see
and to face the truth
so my hope today is that you would
look at the Choice your legislative
forebears made in 1941 and 1951
see how that choice affected individual
human beings and rectify their mistake
in the day characterized by the politics
of division this is a moment to unite
with people of conscience across
boundaries of space and time
I'd like to end on a brief personal note
Randy Cushing was a dear friend of mine
and three weeks before he died I visited
him at his home in Hampton where at that
point he was on a bed in front of the
bay window looking out on the street on
winnekuna Road
and that day being able to see this
build through
so uh of course I said Renny you have
other things to worry about right now
we'll take it from here so I thank you
for your kind attention and I thank you
for seriously considering this bill
thank you
are there any other people wishing to
testify on this bill
seeing none I'm now going to close the
public hearing on HB 89.
the committee will be in recess until 10
45.
okay
foreign
it being 10 45 I'm going to open the
public hearing on hb97 FN
and ask representative Rhodes to
introduce your bill
thank you
good good morning chairman Roy honorable
representatives for the record I'm
representative Jennifer Rhodes I
represent Cheshire County District 17
which is Winchester Richmond Swansea
Troy and Fitzwilliam
I'm here this morning to introduce House
Bill 97 which will establish an
additional penalty for a violation of
privacy
this legislation is truly a bipartisan
effort of state representatives and
Senators to address inconsistencies in
the law when it comes to adequately
protecting individuals against sexual
exploit exploitation especially when it
comes to repeat offenses
last year we had a bill that was in
front of us in the criminal justice
committee that was to establish a study
committee and I had asked a question
during the testimony of that and
basically from my own from my own
question I realized just how serious
this really is and over the summer I
reached out to the coalition to
to work with them to make this bill
become a reality
hb97 is not creating a new law it is
specifically addressing the unlawful and
non-consensual violation of someone's
privacy for sexual arousal or
gratification
the impact of these crimes can be
debilitating
and demoralizing for the victims and
they have long-term very real very
psychological and emotional consequences
victims may suffer from extreme
depression
isolation unemployment Rising medical
costs and homelessness just to name a
few none of which are any fault of their
own
what's worse is often these crimes can
become extremely dangerous over time if
they're not stopped even more concerning
is these crimes also can be signs of
lethal intent if not taken seriously
it is time that we amend the statute to
ensure that we are protecting the
victims against these against being
abused over and over again
there are several individuals that are
in the room today that are going to
testify on behalf of this bill they have
the very real examples
of where this law could have helped the
victims and they also will be able to
explain how the implementation will work
with the other law
so I would respectfully ask
that you
ask the questions for the professionals
that are behind me this morning
please consider passing this bill so we
are better able to support the victims
their families and all of our
communities
thank you representative
the chair calls Pamela kalig
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Pamela kylig and I
am the public policy specialist at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence as some of you know
the Coalition is the umbrella
Organization for our 12 community-based
crisis centers that provide free and
confidential services to nearly 15 000
survivors of sexual and domestic
violence annually I'm here to speak in
support of hb97 legislation that will
bring our state's violation of privacy
statute RSA 6449 into alignment with
other similar laws relative to sexual
violence and exploitation as the good
representative said and thank you so
much for the opportunity to speak today
um I think first and foremost I just
wanted to provide a brief overview of
the legislation and why it's important
RSA 6449 is one of several statutes that
seek to address crimes relating to
sexual violence and abuse and this bill
specifically speaks to paragraph 3A of
the statute that involves videoing and
just observing for the purpose of sexual
gratification and arousal
um and so those
um there's two statues that I just
wanted to briefly highlight and I have
materials that I'll hand out to the
committee after my testimony so RSA 6 45
1 relative to lewdness and indecent
exposure an RSA 652 obscene matter
already have specific Provisions that
address cases where offenders commit the
same crime again and again so this
statute is just looking across the board
when we're treating these crimes and
looking at the specific pattern of
behavior that comes with sexual violence
and making sure that we're addressing
this severity of not only when this
crime happens once but when it happens
again and so I think just it's really
important to highlight that although it
may seem like it's just about a video
recording this can actually escalate
into physical violence and lead to a
significant harm on the victim as well
as making the general family involved or
Community not feeling safe
um
and then I guess I just wanted to also
highlight that violations of privacy can
be co-occurring with acts of stalking
sexual assault domestic violence and
child abuse and offenders in these cases
are seeking to undermine a victim's
sense of safety and control and I'm sure
you're going to hear from other folks in
the room today just like what what we're
really talking about in terms of the
types of behavior involved of
progressively
escalating from you know looking into a
window to eventually breaking into a
house and then potentially even
committing sexual assault so the goal of
this legislation not only to bring it
into alignment with other similar
statutes is to really ensure that the
appropriate interventions come in place
to not only limit the harm to the victim
but also ensure that sex offenders and
individuals perpetuating these crimes
are getting the uh the the support they
need to stop this behavior
um
and I guess um just to kind of
um another part of the handouts that I'm
going to be giving you today highlight a
few case studies that kind of illustrate
how
um this type of behavior can happen over
and over again and we have countless
situations in our state where
individuals have committed acts under
RSA 6449 and later went on um to
committing those physically to
physically assault their victim so I
just wanted to highlight that this is
something we're seeing and something
that we really want to address so I
would just like to conclude by just
asking you all to consider supporting
hb97 and I'd be more than happy to
answer any questions
I have a question
um do you have any information on other
states that have passed similar
legislation
the question I'd be
I'd be um but I don't know off the top
of my head thank you
represent Bolden go ahead thank you um
thanks for taking my question I recall
that there was someone who was arrested
for recording people in restrooms in the
Manchester Mall can you speak to how
this would affect that yeah and I I know
that there's a prosecutor in the room
that might be able to speak more to the
technical aspects of that but I think um
and I might know actually exactly what
case you're referring to
um but I think when we see cases like
that oftentimes it's not just one
restroom and so oftentimes there are
many victims um spanning over multiple
incidences and so when you have right
now it's a I think a misdemeanor level
offense and so but there's no
um way to address a subsequent offense
so the same person might be
convicted for a violation of privacy the
first time and then they could be
convicted again and then again and again
but the penalty is not raising so this
bill specifically is acknowledging when
it happens two or more times to really
ensure that it's being treated seriously
and it's acknowledged that this is this
is um a really really impacts victims
who are experienced seeing this type of
violation of privacy
representative Newell
um that example just kind of brings up a
question for me
um kind of nitpicky but uh does it you
know when we're talking about multiple
cases are we talking about multiple
people for example in that situation uh
they may have viewed many people it's
one incident they would probably go to
court for you know one overall incident
but it could be multiple people so when
we're saying second and third offense
and things like that are we talking
about the person or the incident the
incident okay thank you
thank you
thank you all very much
the chair calls Dr Scott Hampton
I am trainable a little bit slow but I'm
trainable
um
my name is Dr Scott Hampton I'm the
director of of ending the violence which
is an organization in Dover where we
work with perpetrators of Domestic and
Sexual Violence and also offer training
and consultation for other Professionals
in the field
over the last 32 years I've worked with
thousands of perpetrators and victims of
interpersonal violence and my testimony
today is me based on what I've learned
from that experience
um I am here today in support of House
Bill 97 and I do appreciate the
opportunity to share some of my views
about that
um the focus of my testimony is going to
be on the deterrent effect that I
believe the proposed legislation would
have on offenders
um
to do that I'm going to explain the
forces that have not only allowed but
actually encouraged offenders to violate
privacy on route to sometimes committing
even more serious offenses than that
um
to begin I just want to talk about
sexual violence point out that sexual
violence is different from other forms
of assaulted Behavior because it's not
inherently violent it's contextual and
what I mean by that is that for example
sexual intercourse fondling voyeurism
may or may not be a crime
all depending on whether or not there
was fully informed form consent
what that does is it creates some
ambiguity which makes it difficult for
us to sometimes determine whether or not
a sex crime has been committed but even
more importantly it actually makes it
easy for offenders to delude themselves
into thinking that they haven't crossed
some significant line when in fact
they've actually caused a pretty
significant pretty significant harm
um
um so where do they learn this where do
they learn that it's okay actually to
invade someone else's privacy well two
words
sex education
now bear with me for a moment may not be
going the Direction You Think I'm Going
the most popular
sex education program in the world
enthusiastically endorses voyeurism
unfortunately it teaches people
sometimes as young as 10 years old
sometimes even younger that it's okay
not just to look at people who are naked
but actually watch them while they're
engaged and what probably should be a
private sexual encounter with another
person
it also teaches them I do see some
confused looks I'm going to take care of
that in a moment it also teaches them
that it's okay during sexual behavior to
slap strangle degrade humiliate and
commit other acts of violence during
that sexual act
um so what do we call this ubiquitous
sexual education program pornography
multi-billion Dollar business that
unfortunately is the training ground for
for many sex offenders
um even before sex offenders have a
chance to groom their own victims the
institutional pornography has groomed
many of these offenders to commit their
Crimes by sending the message that it's
okay to seek sexual and other forms of
gratification at the expense of another
human being
so why is this so important let me just
give you um like I said I've worked with
a lot of offenders let me just give you
one example it's a generic example of
one person's progression from
voyeuristic activities to something more
severe so this guy walks out of his
house walks down the street notices
um it's night time so it's dark outside
he notices that there's a light on in a
woman's bedroom
he's standing on the sidewalk looks in
sees her getting undressed stands on the
sidewalk watches her okay the next time
he comes out same street same situation
this time he walks halfway onto her yard
wants to get a closer look watches goes
on home next time he walks up to the
window
the next time he waits until she's
asleep walks on to this is how he's
describing to me in group how is
progression work walks onto her front
porch and just stands her from when
seeing what it feels like to be close to
her front door next time he puts his
hand on the door handle doesn't try to
open it but imagines walking inside the
house next time he opens the door closes
it this progresses walks in the house
walks down the hallway goes to the end
of her bedroom goes to the foot of her
bed the final night he violently rapes
her
so it began as a Gateway offense
progressed unabatedly to a violent
sexual act there was no message along
the way there was nothing that said you
have a reason to stop but we have an
opportunity today to give him a reason
to stop
um voyeurism is a gateway offense so
just like a someone who's a drug addict
they start with cigarettes and um and
beer and marijuana before they progress
to cocaine and heroin sex offenders do
the same thing they always describe to
me say well I start off with a low
contact low risk offense like voyeurism
before I Progressive the more severe
even worse offenses like sexual assault
um and rape
um they're not satisfied by pornography
they want to be part of the action so
like that case study I just mentioned
they engage what we call successive
approximations and if along the way no
one is objecting no one is saying this
is not okay no one says you have to stop
they will continue to progress the guys
in my group that's what I'm going to
leave you with
um the men that I've worked with in my
group and I've worked with some women as
well
um describe this gradual escalation from
this low risk low violence onward some
had dozens of victims some had committed
hundreds of sex crimes before there was
any meaningful consequence to them
um
they all told me I had no intention of
stopping until I was gonna until I was
caught until someone said that this was
none of them and this is the important
point for today I think none of them
that I can remember over the 32 years
ever told me that they got that that
firm message because they merely
violated someone's privacy it was always
something more severe than that before
the system said wow this is really not
okay you need to stop doing that
um so victims are waiting for us to send
that message offenders are waiting for
us to send that message I think we all
are waiting for that message to be sent
and I think you have an opportunity
today to deliver that message so thank
you for listening to me
um and and considering my request that
you support House Bill 97 I'd be glad to
answer any questions
representative Bolden
thank you
wanted to clarify where you were
you work
um in in Dover well actually I work in
Dover and I also work in Texas but
that's not relevant today
um uh ending I work in two places ending
the violence uh which is where we work
with offenders I also am the coordinator
for the Stratford County supervised
visitation center so I work with the
offenders the victims and the children
um during a reunification process
follow-up
thank you
um thanks for taking another question so
that is what I was trying to understand
is the stories that you shared are
people that are local to New Hampshire
yes and this one example was was in our
sex offender treatment program probably
10 years ago or so but I've heard
variations on the theme and a lot of
this where one of the one of the what we
do in a treatment program is we we go
through what are called offense cycles
and so we try to do is we map out
um the progression of what they did how
they make decisions what were you
thinking feeling and doing at various
stages and how does that progress over
time and this is a a generic but a very
common presentation that I would hear
representative Staley
good morning thank you for your
testimony
um I live in Durham and you may be
familiar we had a person who was
nicknamed Jack the snipper yes who um
was going into people's homes for those
of you were not familiar and uh breaking
into their spaces and he while they
slept um literally cutting off their
underwear and taking it as trophy how
would this legislation be likely to uh
stop his behavior or to ensure that
um he didn't just continue to be
essentially caught and released like a
fish catch and releases is a really good
analogy for it because I hear that
conversation a lot from the from the
guys in my group I've had people who've
come to my program who've been been
convicted on misdemeanors and
um sometimes they they blow off Groove
they don't really care what the
probation officer is telling them to do
whatever and I've heard them say well um
you know my thing they do constant
comparisons with each other so they'll
say things like well I only got
convicted of a misdemeanor you know that
person got convicted of a felony and you
know so what I did really wasn't all
that bad they're constantly doing these
comparisons so I think when we upgrade
this the same way when we upgraded the
strangulation statute after the Missy
Charbonneau case and that went from a
misdemeanor to a class B felony the
conversations that I heard
um amongst the people in my group
um about wow I never thought it was that
bad and just the fact that it was moved
up to a felony was a tap on the shoulder
and and they're starting to ask me
questions why do they think it's that
bad I thought it was it was it was no
big deal before so I'm imagining there's
going to be the same kind of impact that
we had when we when we upgraded
strangulation just by going from
misdemeanor to felony
foreign
EK this this may be a question for the
chair are we going to hear from someone
from the Judiciary the reason I'm asking
is that we're trivializing a misdemeanor
you've spent you if it where are the
judges on this the misdemeanor carries a
year in jail I mean that's not trivial
and I'm wondering
whether that's ever actually done
as far as I know no one from Judiciary
is going to be taking a position on this
um we could solicit one though
um so the one thing I would say is that
I I completely agree with you if I think
about where I am in life right now
um and if someone said how about we
change your life and and convict you of
a misdemeanor that's going to sting
the Baseline for a lot of people my
program is different
um for some of them a misdemeanor is
like having a bad cold and and something
that they can just take in stride so for
you and me that's a that would be a
significant change for some of them not
so much so
representative Guthrie
just curious
um your program is it for um
changing behaviors what
trying to understand your program when
it comes to
um the person that's assaulted someone
good question
um changing Behavior yes changing the
attitudes and belief systems that
support that behavior even even more
foundational so you know we can say well
you can't do X Y and Z but if they don't
understand why x y and z are a problem
or or the bigger issue then that change
isn't going to last very long so it's
both attitudes and behaviors that feed
into the to the actual actual crimes
they committed
so what would you say your success rate
is at this time
and how long have you been uh in this
process one one of the challenges with
success is that the most common way of
measuring that is what we call
recidivism
there's a problem with that statistic
even though it's a favorite amongst
researchers recidivism doesn't tell you
whether someone's recommitted a crime
recidivism tells you whether someone was
caught
So my answer to how successful we are do
we have people who have chosen not to
recommit those crimes yeah what we try
to do is we say how can you go about
getting your needs met in a way that are
that don't cause problems for you or for
someone else so give them alternatives
are there ways to engage in a healthy
relationship that don't involve invading
someone's privacy for instance so we do
have success for that it's hard to
measure because we have some people who
never get re-arrested but find new ways
of avoiding accountability and so it's
it's a we don't have solid data for that
I'm afraid to say
but what I would say is that that our
success isn't based on what happens in
my program solely it's based on the
community response
so when an entire community
takes an issue seriously we have much
better success it was like someone said
offender programs are are most effective
in communities that don't need them
which is kind of a weird statement if
you think about it but it's true it says
if we all take it seriously then that's
where the change really happens the
program Itself by itself won't do it
legislation my work law enforcement how
much we follow through is important
and I believe the witness testified 32
years
representative scitec well this is
actually slightly off topic I'll make it
quick you're a doctor I believe when
what you said you can change Behavior
can you change the foundational attitude
of someone who is given to this
inclination can that ever change
um it's probably a matter of degree and
they certainly are individual
differences
um we have there are basically three
groups of people who commit sex offenses
there's one group of people who
absolutely want to do harm these are the
more so sociopathic Psychopathic ones
change with them is very difficult and
unlikely and the best we can do is do a
tremendous amount of monitoring and give
them fewer options to to act out
they're the ones who want to cause harm
there are ones on the other end of the
spectrum who really don't want to cause
harm but they're really lacking
information so they really don't
understand boundaries very well and
maybe they grew up in an environment
where boundaries didn't exist or they
were just really distorted those people
we can make a tremendous amount of
change and then there's a group in the
Middle where they don't want to cause
harm but they don't really care if they
do a lot of people who commit what we
call date rapes and stuff are sort of
those like you know I'm going to go out
and you know buyer beware kind of thing
and they're kind of in the middle so we
can have a significant impact on them
when we when we offer alternatives to
them but there's some people that are
untouchable
representative Noel
thank you
um thank you for taking my question sure
is your program a mandated
um a part of a recovery
um scheme or something like that or is
it voluntary
um
so I'm going to change the question a
little bit most of the people coming to
our program are court ordered
um we do get some people who are
otherwise referred so in other words
when we talk about voluntary that makes
it sound like they just on their own
want to do it we have people who have
other reasons like oh my partner said if
I don't come to your program he's going
to leave me well is that voluntary it's
not court ordered but yeah you sort of
see where I'm going with that we used to
do just um Court mandate but what's
interesting is that we've had people
talking with other people I have a guy
in my program he talks to someone that
he goes to work with and I just had
someone about three months ago who said
this he said um I've never been arrested
for committing for committing this kind
of crime however I want to keep it that
way and and can I be part of the
conversation so I get a phone call
saying you know I'm not Court referred
but I could use some of the stuff you
guys talk about are your doors open and
I say yes so I would say we have about
15 of the people in our program that are
otherwise referred the rest are court
ordered thank you sure
there'll be no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you for
your time
the chair calls Stephen
and and there's Enders
you have to Pardon Me on my reading
glasses today
I have Spears
good morning chairman members of the
committee my name is Steven Andrus I'm a
prosecutor in the Merrimack County
Attorney's Office I'm an assistant
County attorney I've been a prosecutor
for a little over 20 years now
um really what we're talking about here
is punishment for a crime which is
really a policy decision for the
legislature to make and certainly Dr
Hampton is giving you some
some reasons to consider that policy I
mean personally as a prosecutor I
support the idea of an increased
sentence for a second offense I spoke to
County attorney Halverson earlier today
he also indicated that he supported this
legislation
really there's a number of statutes in
New Hampshire where we already have
secondary subsequent offenses with
increased punishment or increased
criminal liability
indecent exposure has passages for
second or subsequent offenses being
felonies stalking has a provision where
a second or subsequent offense can be
charged as a felony cruelty to animals
has
felony Provisions for subsequent
offenses
even theft in New Hampshire a third
offense can be charged as a felony
regardless of value and then throughout
the motor vehicle code there's there's
examples where subsequent offenses have
higher penalties such as operating after
suspension or driving while intoxicated
for example
to explain a little bit about how it
actually works in practice
a person would have to be arrested
charged with a violation of 644.9 and
then convicted of that violation and
after conviction commit a subsequent
offense for this to be charged as a
felony offense
so there were questions about multiple
victims that type of thing if you did
this if you committed a violation of
privacy against 10 people with no prior
convictions all 10 of those would end up
being charged as misdemeanors you'd have
to be convicted at least once and then a
subsequent offense could be charged as a
as a felony level offense
but as I said this is in line with other
New Hampshire statutes and certainly as
a policy decision for for the
legislature to make
happy to answer any questions
I have a question would this legislation
if it were passed and signed into law
would it assist you in obtaining plea
Bargains and things of that nature
absolutely I think it would assist in
in working cases out I think it would
also perhaps assist in maybe not having
subsequent cases because as Dr Hampton
said if you're convicted the first time
and you're told if you do this again
it's a felony that may deter your
behavior
certainly as representative Saitek
mentioned before a misdemeanor is not a
trivial offense an offender can spend up
to a year in jail for a misdemeanor
level offense
however
our goal isn't always to incarcerate
people in fact that's not our goal at
all and if I had a person charged with
violation of privacy one of the things I
would want is for them to participate in
a program like Dr Hampton offers so I
would probably do a suspended sentence
or a proportion of that sentence
suspended conditioned on them receiving
treatment I can only hang 12 months over
their head
and it's in a suspended sense
if it was a felony level offense
obviously there's there's a greater
ability to incarcerate a person on a
felony level offense there's also
um collateral consequences of a felony
conviction which we may be able to to
bargain with to get that person
hopefully into treatment and the help
that they need
thank you could you just briefly to the
committee explain on first offenses is
there any type of a continuance where
there's not a conviction
um like a without a finding type of
thing where this would not be triggered
certainly
um
there's a range of penalties that we can
we can sort of discuss for first
offenses with the
there's a range of
of conviction and non-conviction
um resolutions to criminal cases we send
criminal cases to Diversion on a regular
basis where diversion is a program that
if you go through a certain program take
classes maybe perform community service
we would agree not to prosecute you for
the crime there's no set rule that says
we can't send a violation of privacy
case to Diversion
um I'd be unlikely to send a violation
or privacy case to Diversion because of
the nature of the case
um
so there are absolutely non-conviction
resolutions that could occur
um there are conviction resolutions that
could occur
and as we had said you can get anything
from no time in the house Corrections up
to 12 months stand committed there can
be fines up to two thousand dollars we
could have follow-up treatment
uh
there's possibilities of a conditional
discharge on a misdemeanor case where
after you fulfill the conditions of your
sentence the the conviction would
essentially be vacated so there's a
there's certainly a variety of tools
that wouldn't be unique to this statute
but in general exist for all misdemeanor
and felony prosecution
thank you
representative Bolden
thank you thanks for taking my question
um I appreciate hearing that you believe
that you could potentially If This Were
to pass
um arranged for
agreements where someone would enter
treatment under a suspended sentence and
I assume good behavior do you see that
being more common
I I'm asking because I can see that the
benefits of maybe not having people in
the jails as much absolutely
um it says in the New Hampshire
Constitution that the purpose of the
criminal justice system is essentially
Rehabilitation so Rehabilitation is
something that whenever we're crafting a
sentence is something that we're looking
at
um
so
in almost every
offer I've ever made as a prosecutor
there's been some degree of
Rehabilitation within that offer
um
jail is even
in my opinion partially a form of
Rehabilitation because it may cause you
to look at what you've done and uh think
perhaps you don't want to do that in the
future
so whenever I had I knew that whenever
I've had violation of privacy cases
there's always been a sex offender
treatment aspect to those sentences
representative sailing
thank you so much you heard my question
to Dr Hampton I believe about
a community
um I'm curious how your perspective of
how this might potentially stop someone
like him from perpetuating his behaviors
and also what you see is the potential
downfalls of this type of legislation
um I'm not completely familiar with with
the the snipper case I know I heard
about it on the news if that individual
didn't have a prior conviction this
legislation wouldn't affect him at all
this would only affect subsequent
convictions my recollection from that
case as you indicated that he was
actually entering people's homes and I
would assume that instead of being
charged with violation and privacy that
he would have been charged with burglary
which is a felony level offense for
breaking and entering into the dwelling
of another with the intent to commit a
crime therein with the crime either
being theft of of the underwear or the
crime being violation of privacy so I
think that there's
there are felony level statutes that
sort of address some of this Behavior
especially when you're entering people's
houses I would expect that you would be
charged with burglary rather than
um violation of privacy
representative Newell answers your
question
the chair
um that question kind of brought up
another question from me which is if
there is some type of diversion or
program uh when you say non-conviction
options what we're talking about here is
based on incidences how many incidences
so it kind of Builds on itself right and
what I'm curious about is if it's a
non-conviction option which I think
could be a good option but does that
count towards this where a second or
third offense would have would carry a
different weight it would not count
toward this so you would need a
conviction for a subsequent offense to
be a felony so if a first offense was
sent to Diversion for whatever reason
I don't want to say that would that
would end up being a freebie for the the
purposes of this statute but it wouldn't
count as a prior conviction okay thank
you
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else in the audience
wishing to testify down this bill today
they're being none I'm going to go ahead
and close the public hearing on HP 97 FN
and the committee will be in recess
until 11 45.
we're expecting more
six I'm going to go ahead and open the
public hearing on H HP
107 FN and I'm going to turn sharing
this hearing over to the vice chair
because I'm a co-sponsor
thank you Mr chairman
um representative verville
here to introduce the bill
thank you madam chair honorable members
of the of the committee
um it's like deja vu all over again so
this is the this is the third time
this bill Works its way wins its way
through the house
um
the first time it passed the house and
died in a senate Omnibus Bill
last term it passed the house and a very
nice bipartisan vote
and uh went over to the the Senate where
they decided interim study
so maybe the third time's a charm I
don't I don't know
so this bill was
requested from a constituent of mine in
in Deerfield and there's some papers
working around for two news stories from
the Genesis of this
of this bill I emailed them to you so
you don't need the paper copy if you
don't want it
you heard a lot of testimony this
morning that carries over to this bill
very very nicely and so
what this bill
aims to do
is to prevent
registered sex offenders
from hiring managing
and supervising minors
doesn't prevent them working
at a business
that has minors present
it just prevents them from being placed
in a managing managing or supervisory
role
of minors
and
working directly
with them
this serves two purposes
one
it protects our miners
against being potential prey to
registered sex offenders
we heard discussion earlier about
recidivism rates on registered sex
offenders and it's if not the highest
one of the most highest recidivism rates
of any crime
and we also heard interesting testimony
that when we talk about recidivism we're
talking about people that get caught
so the rate is likely much much higher
because not everybody gets caught
and so for that reason
this bill
this change in the law all right this is
not new law this is a this is to close a
loophole
in existing RSA
that will protect the registered sex
offender
so if it prohibits the registered sex
offender from doing something how does
it protect them
it protects them because it prevents
them being placed into a position
where to recommit the crime or similar
crime is not presented to them
so it it prevents putting them where
they're likely to to reoffend
last term and I know it's a new term and
it's a it's a new house I I get all that
last term
we had a subcommittee
we did great work
the language that's in front of you
came out of that subcommittee
this is language that was approved by
State Police
prosecutor's office
victims advocates
as well as offender Advocates right
everybody has an advocate and everybody
should have an advocate and we all came
around the table Republicans Democrats
victims people that are trying to to fix
their lives for mistakes they've made in
the past and we all agreed that this
language was good language that this
language closes the loophole that
currently exists in our law that allows
um situations like you see going around
to occur
so the first was
a landscaper
from my community
registered sex offender was hiring and
directly managing directly supervising
minors that that puts both the minor and
the offender in in a potentially very
dangerous position
and the intent of the law was to to
disallow that but the law
by interpretation by the courts
does not does not prevent it and so the
law needs to be changed so it does
the second incident
I was a
carnival ride operator
working for the vendor that provided
rides at the Deerfield Fair
an operator
is a registered sex offender
is operating a ride
physically assisting children both on
and off the ride
checking restraints checking buckles so
very close proximity
we all know that minor children have
favorite rides and therefore are likely
to Loop through and ride that ride many
times providing many opportunities for
for contact that that this law was
designed to prevent
but as it was originally written
in the eyes of the Court does not and so
this language merely closes
an accidental loophole an existing New
Hampshire law
I would strongly encourage every member
of this committee to vote in favor of
this
so that we can we can bring it to the
floor of the House pass it for a third
time
and then hopefully get it through the
through the other body
that's the intent of the law this
language has been gone over many times
and and so that's uh that's what we're
looking to do here today
thank you representative are there any
questions from the committee
representative Muse
yes um
um does your bill actually include the
language that was suggested by
representative Lynn last year
in his Amendment
so for those that are new and for those
that have been with us for a while
this when this bill came to the floor of
the house
representative Lynn
offered a floor Amendment
I don't know what his motivation was he
didn't testify in the committee when the
bill came before committee
he didn't participate or attend the
subcommittee hearings
and he never reached out to myself or
any of the co-sponsors on the bill
and so
I was a little surprised by the floor
Amendment
the effect of the floor amendment in my
opinion
would change language
to leave the loophole open
so while the language was changed under
that floor Amendment it would have left
the loophole open so it sounded nice but
it removed the the teeth
and so there was a floor debate on the
Lynn Amendment
and that floor amendment was
resoundingly defeated on the floor of
the house and so no this bill does not
include the language of the the one
Amendment
thank you for the question
representative
representative Bolden
thank you thanks for taking my question
um my perception is that there's
different levels of being a Regis
required to register on the sex offender
registry I don't know if that's accurate
um but you have in your handouts here at
Edward Proctor and David getchell were
those
people convicted of crime against minors
to your knowledge
thank you for the for the question
um I do not know the the specifics of
the crimes they committed uh but they
were convicted of sexual crimes and are
forced to register as as far as
I believe they both were but I I
couldn't I couldn't swear an oath to it
so if I may Madam chairman
I'm not an expert
in the registered sex offender database
one of the challenges
that we know we face is when we when we
try to get too fine when we try to put
too fine a point on it when we try to
get too granular
the language starts to get difficult and
and is more open to interpretation
the
to be quite Frank
the most of the opposition to closing
this loophole
is a fear that it will further reduce
limited employment opportunities for
registered sex offenders and the
original language
potentially
could have prevented
a registered sex offender
from becoming a corner store corner
store clerk
because
come in after school they buy candy he's
the clerk she's the clerk they're making
a transaction so they're they're
servicing children but they're they're
they're not right they're not in a
direct supervisory uh type of type of
role the business is not to provide
services to children to the general
public so those sort of incidentally
incidental type um encounters
um I I agree we don't want to Bear to
ban them
and it it was argued that well gee whiz
you know
you could you could have a a landscaping
Crow of of three people and so perhaps
one of them is a registered sex offender
perhaps one's actually the the
supervisor and then the third employee
is a minor
so would that be okay
yes
until the supervising manager has to go
somewhere else until they're called off
that location and now the minor child is
Left Behind on a job site with the
registered sex offender at that point it
becomes a problem so if if the trio has
to be broken apart then then the the
registered sex offender has to be the
the third person out
right The Miner has to go with the
non-registered sex offender so that
they're not left alone
that's that's the thing we don't want
them we don't want them alone with
children because that's when you have
these these opportunities
thank you madam chair
Representative no
thank you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I'm curious you know just looking
through this one of the example cases
that was handed out here and it says
Edward Proctor of Deerfield was
previously convicted of a sexual assault
and at the time of his arrest in 2016
was listed on the State Sex Offender
Registry however he no longer appears on
the list and that's I'm saying
um is there a statute of limitations for
how long you're on the sex offender list
it seems like these cases are are fairly
serious so I I'm just shocked to to hear
that someone would not would no longer
be on the list
thank you for the question so again I am
not an expert on the sex offender
registry
um and and happy not to be to be quite
Frank
I I don't know the circumstances as to
how
um that person came off the the registry
my my understanding and you have to take
it with a grain of salt I am not a
lawyer I don't want to play a lawyer but
my understanding is basically when
you're put on the registry you're
essentially put on for life and and
there is some debate whether that's
appropriate or not appropriate and if
somebody wants to file legislation to to
address those issues I I wouldn't
discourage that from being considered
my my guess is
um there was probably some change in his
status either either there was an appeal
and it got overturned
um and and that allowed for for him to
come off the road I don't know I don't
know the details
um you know once that person's off the
registry then they don't have to worry
about any of this right it's it's it's
only when they're on the registry and
they they have they have a duty they
have an obligation to notify potential
employers right
so that that nobody is is is caught in
in arrears but that's
we're just look
I I won't lie to you my my intention is
to protect children right that my
constituent came to me and requested
this and and when I looked into it I
said yeah this this needs to be
addressed and it was upon further review
that I realized that this is protecting
both sides right we are we are we are
protecting potential victims from being
victimized and we are protecting uh past
offenders from reoffending by not
putting them into a position where we're
doing both groups a favor
as for the employment opportunities you
know we we are blessed
that we live in New Hampshire because we
have a very very resilient job market we
typically have one of the lowest if not
the lowest unemployment rates in the
nation
I'm old enough to have lived through the
recession of the 1980s and we had a lot
of economy in a few baskets and it hit
and it hurt and New Hampshire went to
Great Lengths to diversify our economy
so the next downturn didn't take
everything down with it and that's a
success story for New Hampshire and so
there are plenty of job opportunities
for these people other than directly
supervising directly working with minor
children I I don't and we can all make
our own decisions on this for sure but I
don't see this bill this closing of a
loophole being overly burdensome on
anybody
thank you for the question
I just would like to take a moment and
point out to the committee that there is
a statute for registered sex offenders
and my understanding is it depends on
the time of the sentencing uh whenever
our researcher comes back in I could ask
him to look that up for us or if
somebody has a computer out and would
like to but I do know that they answer
the question has been going around there
that there is a statute for that
representative Boulder you have another
question
I was hoping to figure out and maybe
there's something Fred
can do and I could just email Brad and
ask him and I guess he can like send the
answer to everyone but to understand if
there's different levels of registering
on the sex offender registry and if
there's a difference between is that
what you were saying yeah that's exactly
what I was saying okay when he comes
back and if there's a way to
to
um
differentiate between sex offenses as it
relates to this bill also thanks yep
when when our researcher uh returns I'll
certainly ask him to that and send the
information to all the committee because
it seems like we all a lot of us have
the same question are there any other
questions for the representative
representative Newman
foreign
I have a question I don't know if you're
aware of uh representative Lynn has sent
email around that suggested a change to
this and he gave an example about a
child
that may get director Services which I
think would be probably an extreme case
but in Market Basket where the child
might come up and buy something a minor
might might do that and I I so I read
the bill and it says Direct Services to
to minors
and I'm just wondering if that's an
inclusive or exclusive enough
that the language and the bill would not
affect that kind of situation
thank you for the question
representative I I appreciate it we've
gone around on this quite a bit and
um you know the prosecutors the state
police the the victims Advocates the the
offenders Advocates
um were certainly not uncomfortable with
this language when we did the
subcommittee
um I understand that representative Lynn
has that as a concern
um I I don't I think the interpretation
of Direct Services is when that is the
purpose of the business is to provide
Direct Services an example would be a
private school that that is a business
that provides Direct Services to minor
children and
um you know that's already prohibited in
other parts of of Statute right so
um
all right
I don't believe
that if I'm working at a grocery store I
hate to use brand names right because
because they have they have competition
so I'm I'm I'm a registered sex offender
I'm working at a grocery store
and I manage the bread aisle
and a child comes down the aisle because
the parent sent them off go get English
muffins
and the child is looking and can't find
English muffins
sees me in a store clerk uniform and
says excuse me sir where can I find the
English muffins and I say the English
muffins are there
right that did I provide a direct
service yeah I gave him location of the
English muffins
I'm not in a supervisory role I'm not in
a managerial role over that person has
an appointment this is a this is an
employee thing so so that's a that's a
customer so I don't I don't think that
that fits the the definition
now I again I'm not a lawyer you know
can somebody drag it out that that far
you know maybe so and so let the
employer decide what position they want
that that person to have you know
there's plenty of jobs that aren't
customer facing in most of these
businesses that these people could could
fill so if we're going to air in any
direction
I would suggest it's our duty our
responsibility to err on the side of
caution
instead of airing on on the side of of
some minuscule chance of a what if I'll
flush it out further if if if he'll
indulge me
so I'm the parent that just sent the
child to me to find the English muffins
right
and so
how am I going to know
that the bread clerk is a registered sex
offender and then file some sort of
complaint on a one-time interaction like
that
I I think I don't believe that that's I
don't believe that's reasonable to think
that that would
um that that would occur
in fact I would go a step further and
say I don't have children
and I know I'm a registered sex offender
and I see myself working in a in a store
I could tell the story you know that
person is on the registered sex offender
list and you have them working in a job
where they're near children and you
should you should consider doing some
due diligence around that my my gut
tells me any employer that was notified
of of that
um would take that seriously and and
take some some corrective actions there
it's it's hypothetical but you're asking
a hypothetical so no I I don't
a business providing Direct Services to
minors
minors I don't believe a grocery store
provides Direct Services to minors I
don't I don't believe that the clerk at
a local convenience store that is
selling items to to Children before or
after school is providing Direct
Services I mean you're selling Goods but
I I don't I don't believe that that's
the case
follow-up representative Newman
I probably should not have mentioned the
public business I probably should be
more generic I don't have any uh
any I don't oppose anything that you
said I agree with everything that you've
said about that it was a hypothetical
one and maybe an extreme one I only
asked the question for
to find out I'm not a lawyer just to
clarify the language and what your
opinion was and I appreciate your answer
my question is and this is just because
I'm kind of a geeky kind of person is do
you in the law is there and maybe
someone else can answer this question in
the law is there or in New Hampshire law
is there any actual definition in any of
the statutes that describes the term
um provides Direct Services to minors uh
you I don't know whether you know that
or not but I'd just be curious thank you
uh thank you for the question
representative it's it's actually an
excellent question
um I do not know where that it would be
defined um in in RSA
but again
I will loop back to my position that if
we are going to air we should err on the
side of caution we should err on the
side of protecting children and we
should err on the side of preventing
opportunities for people to commit again
thank you representative just to clarify
you are saying that if a person owns an
arcade
and a person comes in and applies for a
job that is a knowing registered sex
offender
that that would be a perfect example of
a place that that
sex offender should not be seeking
employment
no I don't I don't believe that that
statement as made is correct so I get
people get mad at me because they say
I'm too specific on language so I own an
arcade registered sex offender comes in
applies for work are they prohibited
from working there I would say no they
are not they they should not be managing
other employees that are minors under
them
um if if I owned a business like that
because there were all are already
certain
um
prescriptions in law that would not be a
good candidate if my arcade is
frequented by children which we all know
they are it it's
so it goes back to the carnival ride
operator can I work for the carnival
ride company yes I can I can set rides
up I can break rides down I can clean
rides at night I should not be helping
children on and off rides on a
repetitive basis so is there a job at
the at the arcade for a registered sex
offender sweeping the floors after the
children are gone absolutely things like
that sure
any employer
that's hiring registered sex offenders
that are going to be
doing that kind of work I think I don't
think they would do that if I would
think
it's actually clear did a great job of
clarifying that thank you very much are
there any other questions from
I would call that last statement
is that a question
yeah
isn't that a loophole that yes they can
come work for that it's supposed to work
sweep the floors but now they're short
one day and he's out on the floor
the the short one day shouldn't simply
shouldn't be allowed so it goes back to
the landscaper so I have a registered
sex offender that's on a landscaping on
a landscaping team he can't be the
manager he can't be the supervisor of
the minor that's that's what we're
disallowing
that's and I apologies thank you for the
question
representative scitec
I see in the present law which I think
I see in the present law not limited to
uh involving the care instruction
Guidance the language that struck out
but not limited to
and it seems to me that the court has
tried to balance
uh competing rights here uh I don't see
why the president law isn't working your
constituent's unhappy but these are
aren't egregious examples I'm reading
here it seems like the court has
balanced
um
I don't know if that's quite a question
but what's wrong with the present law
thank you representative that is an
excellent question and I apologize if I
if I have not made the answer to that
clear
first of all where we're striking out
the examples uh because they're they're
often
um used to narrow focus and we don't
want a narrow Focus
the problem with the current law
is it puts minors
under direct supervision under direct
management
right direct supervision or oversight of
minors
you're putting them in close proximity
so you're putting a registered sex
offender and a minor together
I used to be
a school teacher
and every school teacher job I ever had
and I only had a handful but I had a
handful every
teaching job I had I had to pass a
criminal background check
do you know why we have criminal
background checks for teachers I know
you do because I know you're a former
educator as well and we
I I apologize current educator
we do that because we don't want
registered sex offenders or or people
with with
bad criminal backgrounds working in
schools with children we do that to
protect the children in that case we do
not do that to to protect the the person
seeking employment we do it to protect
the children
all right
why do you rob banks
because that's where the money is
Okay so
this is to protect children beyond the
schoolhouse setting if it's good enough
for a public school
it's good enough for children everywhere
I mean I guess the question is
what closing the loop what is the damage
what is the damage of closing this
loophole
it's a rhetorical question answer it
your own way in your own head
what's the potential damage
if we don't close the loophole
okay
so most of us are probably parents
and if we're not I would assume we love
and cherish children
what is the damage if we don't close the
loophole
that damage the damage of not close at
the potential damage of not closing the
loophole in my opinion is far greater
than any any protection or any lack of
damage on on the other side of the
Ledger
in my opinion this is a loophole that
needs to be closed the house is voted in
favor of this legislation twice before
first time it died in an ominous Bill
Omnibus Bill
I guess both are correct
um
last year because
people are a little nervous this might
be too too constricting
and it's my colleague from the house who
we've referred to earlier
and it and it got interim studied in the
Senate and the Senate hasn't done
anything
we've passed it twice we should pass it
a third time we should bring it to the
other body we should get this pass we
should close this loophole and we should
protect New Hampshire children that's
what we should do that's that's my
long-winded answer
thank you representative I believe that
we have asked the representative I think
that we're going to move on from here uh
thank you very much representative for
your presentation Mr Greenland while you
are out we have some questions we were
hoping that you could help us with
um we have some questions around the
the sex offender registry and how long a
person would would be put on there and
our understanding is you know it kind of
goes with it whenever they're sentenced
would you be able to get us some some
facts on the
the registry for sex offenders and send
it out to the entire committee thank you
very much
Mrs Graham
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to speak to you today regarding HB 107
FN relative to employment restrictions
for registered sex offenders
my name is Jane Graham and I am the
Strategic Communications administrator
for the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections with me is Abby Simon Abby
is the administrator of sex offender
treatment and Behavioral Health for the
Department
of Corrections is neutral on HB 107.
as the largest Rehabilitation treatment
provider for sexual offenders in the
state of New Hampshire the Department of
Corrections supports legislation to
safeguard individuals and families
living in our community
we want to do all that we can to protect
our children and keep them from falling
victim to those who do them harm
while HB 107 has the greatest of
intentions we ask the committee to
consider the use of more specific
language in regard to providing Direct
Services to minors or supervision or
oversight of minors
as a department our goal is to assist
those who are incarcerated in their
successful and safe re-entry into the
community this includes transitioning
individuals who have been convicted of
sexual offenses
the broad language in HB 107 could have
unintended consequence of restricting
employment options for a group of people
already at a disadvantage when entering
the workforce
many individuals enter fields of retail
or Food Service upon their release from
incarceration
this bill will this bill prevent them
from working in industries that sell
their products to minors or who serve
food to minors will this prevent
a sexual offender from becoming a shift
supervisor at a fast food restaurant
because they would be providing direct
supervision to minors
the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections agrees with the existing
risk restrictions listed in current law
and even go a step further to include
others such as school bus driver or
employment at a business whose primary
intent is to deliver services to minors
such as arcades trampoline parks Etc
employment is vital for successful
reintegration into the community these
individuals need employment to afford
treatment and engage in positive healthy
and appropriate activities by further
restricting a person with a sexual
offenses employment it inadvertently
increases risk factors through reduced
unemployment reduced employability thus
increasing the likelihood of reoffence
stable employment provides the structure
necessary to assist individuals with a
successful transition and provides them
with the income necessary to obtain
housing and treatment to prevent
homelessness
according to David Prescott a researcher
for the association for the treatment of
sexual abusers research has shown that
offenders who are able to maintain
stability in their homes and employment
are less likely to commit further crimes
public policy is therefore most
effective when it considers those
factors that prevent crime as well as
those that make communities safer
in closing I would like to reiterate the
Department of Corrections support for
legislation that keeps our community
safe it would urge the committee to
consider the use of more specific
languages they move forward thank you
for this opportunity and for your time
I'm happy to answer any questions or and
I brought Abby with me because she's the
expert so
thank you for your testimony are there
any representative Bolden
thank you
um thanks for taking my question
um I know that the grocery store we're
not going to mention anymore that is a
pinnacle of this community
um hires at 14.
is it currently legal for to your
knowledge
um and I know that I'm the lawmaker but
is it currently legal for a business
like that to put a convicted sex
offender in a position of authority over
someone who's 14 who's maybe a co-worker
I'm not a lawyer but I can tell you that
at a super like a supermarket
Mike they're not running a criminal
background check so if someone did
become a supervisor I would say yes
current law allows for that because you
wouldn't even know
most likely
hold on one second representative scitec
uh you have obviously have prepared
remarks do you mind emailing that to us
yes and I have written copies as well
that I'm happy to provide I can give to
them my nails fine okay great
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question when
you say more specific language
um it looks like the way that the law is
written now is they actually make an
attempt to identify specific situations
what what the bill would do is actually
generalize these these situations in in
certain ways
can can you tell me why the doc thinks
it's important that we actually get
insultingly specific with the with the
conditions in this particular bill
um I do think so again I reference that
a good portion of our responsibility is
to make sure people safely transition
back into communities
um if we have language that's broad that
prevents people from getting a stable
job that prevents us from safely
rehabilitating folks and getting them
into a stable environment so that they
don't reoffend I know Abby if you want
to add do you have anything to add or
you
does that answer your question
representative or do you want me to get
a little bit more specific
um actually if if you could be more
specific about things that that actually
so for instance um the the current law
actually lays out some specific
situations where this this is prohibited
um does the doc think having uh some uh
additional uh conditions
um that would actually uh potentially
address some of Representative verbal's
concerns
um does it does the doc think it's
worthwhile for us to look at adding
things like that absolutely we would be
supportive of looking at more specific
examples of
situations that you would not want a
registered sex offender to be in we just
feel that this language is too broad
thank you thank you
I I actually have a question you had
mentioned you know the rehabilitation
process and you know people getting back
to work and being members of society my
question is
will you give us an example
of the percentage of sex offenders that
re-offend or are re-offenders do you
know that
um we don't have the statistics in front
of us I'd be happy to give that to you
as soon as possible so we can we can do
that and send you information out there
I actually would find that very helpful
thank you are there any other questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
Mr
parole
certain I slaughtered that
good afternoon sorry I lost my voice I'm
uh Richard Perrault I'm a detective
Sergeant with the New Hampshire State
Police and I am the commander of the sex
offender registry here in New Hampshire
um again that's uh that's who I am uh
I'm here obviously today to
um provide some testimony into this
state police is not taking a position
for or against the proposed law however
uh the language I think in the proposed
law is is vague and open to
interpretation uh for example the
definition of what a direct service is
um that can mean a lot of different
things to a lot of different people
as we're all seeing in here today
there's also
no definition of what a criminal
background check is
the in the proposed law
or Republic or private employer
organization whose primary intent is to
provide Direct Services to minors
will conduct a criminal background check
does that include a criminal record
check or Does it include
you know the employer calling his last
previous three jobs and finding out if
he actually worked there so
uh those things I think are a little too
vague
I understand this is obviously by
reading this this is kind of an
amendment to the law
that already uh talks about providing
Direct Services to minors
um
there are
to convolute this a little more
there are some offenses sex offenses
that do not require
registration
it's quite a convoluted system
so those things that are
maybe will pop up in a background
criminal record check but that subject
may not be on the sex offender registry
so if the employer goes to the sex
offender registry to find find out if
this offender if the subject or
applicant is an offender that obviously
will not will not populate in the system
as far as fiscal impacts I know I was
supposed to talk about that briefly I I
don't know what the fiscal impact I
don't have hard numbers on that however
we at the sex offender registry continue
to get calls
weekly more daily of employers who
actually ask us hey
you know we want to hire this guy he's
on the list can we hire them
so I would imagine in this case if
they're required to do criminal
background checks that's going to
require
either fingerprints or submission of
criminal record check through the state
those calls are going to uh
you know be more likely to happen
more frequently than than now
so again State Police is not taking a
position either way but I think the
language in this should be should be
cleaned up
thank you very much representative
Newman
thank you for taking my question
hi there different degrees of background
checks is that why there is a problem
with not having a legal definition of
what a background check is well I think
you know if you ask if you ask me what a
background check is I've done
you know 15 or at least probably 10 to
15 background checks on new hires for us
a background check for me would be uh
everything from
getting his criminal his or her criminal
record from the state speaking with
previous employers speaking with
neighbors speaking with
um
you know previous employers to see how
he was as an employee that's a
background check to me
background check to
the owner of a small convenience store
could be
calling Walmart and Burger King and
Target and the last three places that he
that he or she worked that could be his
background check and it may not pop up
or may not indicate that he's a sex
offender if he's not running if he or
she is not running a criminal background
check through the state
thank you sir
representative Selleck
thank you thanks for your time and for
taking my question
um you as as well as the Department of
Corrections both referenced using more
specific language
um could ask you what language you would
find specific enough
you know I don't know ma'am um but I
think
where it says employment in businesses
providing Direct Services to minors or
direct supervision or oversight of
minors I think that's
could be interpreted a lot of different
ways when I
talked to some some people
earlier today and this week regarding
this bill
the first thing that popped up was wait
a minute
my kid can't go to Dairy Queen and buy
an ice cream
I said well I don't think that's the
intent of the law
but that's the way he interpreted it
when I asked him that
you know if you ask somebody that owns a
landscape company maybe they're going to
have a different interpretation of that
so I think it I really don't know
how to word that better
but I think
I think it's open to a lot of
interpretation
yes
representative
um I'm just trying to parse out and I
think we are going to be getting a
little bit more information
um around this but I'm curious you know
I mean how would someone be on uh you
would do a criminal records check right
criminal background check you would find
an offense that is a sexual nature yes
but what you're saying is they might it
might come up in that but they wouldn't
be on the sex offender list and so I'm
just I'm really curious why that would
happen you know why someone would not be
on the so it is it is quite convoluted
um but you know as an example
uh indecent exposure indecent exposure
and lewdness if the victim is not under
16 it is not registerable unless they do
it twice in five years
so if you could have a situation where
you know uh you've got well I mean it
kind of outlines it there you've got a
situation where you've got a gentleman
urinating and then you know on the side
of a building
in front of a
you know 17 year old
it's not registerable but if he does it
again and
five years it's going to be so he
is convicted of that indecent exposure
but he's it's going to show up on his
criminal record but he's not on the he's
not on the registration
so you've got there are you know a few
examples of that so
the other part of that to answer your
question if
if businesses that provide Direct
Services to minors and again that's a
that's a broad statement
I it's my belief that those
the certain the certain sex acts
um or the certain convictions of sexual
acts
the ones that they have to register for
possibly should be in that law as well
so that it's it's very clear-cut because
what's going to happen is you've got the
manager of a small convenience store now
having to do a criminal background check
and gets his criminal background check
but doesn't necessarily know how to
interpret that and see you know well you
were convicted of this so you're not
going to have a job here
well I don't have to register not on the
registry yeah I urinated on a building
but I'm clearly not well you're not
going to get the job so I think and
that's going to cause uh
that's going to cause multiple
my opinion questions calls to local
jurisdictions local PDS my office to
clarify those things for different
businesses does that make sense yes it
does I'd like to ask a follow-up if
possible okay
um
I think in my reading of this the the
onus is put on the individual the person
who has a record or you know
um so it
in the in the way that this is written
it doesn't clarify to my knowledge or
you know the way that I'm reading it
that it would be a responsibility of the
business owner it would be the
responsibility of the individual who is
trying to get a job or something like
that that they would be the person who
is responsible for that in the end
I see that a person is guilty of a class
B felony have been convicted the
jurisdiction and the paragraph or he or
she knowingly fails to provide that
information so I agree that the owner
can only do he can only work with what
he has for information so if that
applicant leaves that off
however
however now if that applicant fills out
that packet properly with his name
date of birth all his information and
the owner of that business is required
to do a criminal background check and
does that not only if that you know
comes to light that he's now a sex
offender
that applicant's going to be charged I
would imagine for knowingly leaving that
off and he's not going to get the job so
thank you
thank you for your testimony Sergeant um
seeing no more pink cards we will now
close the public hearing for us Bill 107
what
manager could I ask Gene Graham to stick
around after the hearing
thank you
um we're going to be appointing I know
some people probably had some more
questions I'm going to appoint a
subcommittee on this
um so we'll be able to flush out um any
more questions that you have so on the
subcommittee
um it's going to be representative
chaired by representative Manion
representative Newell representative
Muse
representative Bolden
and representative Pearl
to add his experience to that
I didn't make you the chair
if you have questions representative
Manning just ask me after him
okay at this time we're going to open
the public hearing on HB 287
and call
the next bill none
I'm going to say to have a sponsor here
that's new it should be normal yeah she
needs more
um
thank you chairman Roy
um I am I will be introducing
um HB 287
I feel like there was a certain way I
was supposed to say that but it's my
first time so bear with me
my name is Jody Newell I am representing
Cheshire 4 which is a little Slice of
Heaven over there in Keene
so the bill that I'm introducing today
uh removing testing equipment from the
definition of drug paraphernalia in the
controlled Drug Act that actually should
be testing and analyzing equipment
um I'm going to keep it very brief it is
a very very brief piece of legislation
it's pretty quick I think you probably
would have read through it in uh in
about two minutes so I will try not to
take up a whole lot of time
um so the idea of removing this from the
definition of drug paraphernalia is that
there is a little bit of confusion
um and uh you know vagueness around what
is considered drug paraphernalia and
then how that gets used
um how people are responsible I think
we're all familiar with um fentanyl test
strips and things like that that's uh
that would fall under this heading But
it includes other ones like spectrometer
and things like that we all know that we
have a substance use issue the opiate
overdose crisis is still raging in New
Hampshire fortunately
um in contrast to a lot of other states
our overdose deaths went down I would
like to call out the fact that it was
the accessibility
and the use encouraged use of harm
reduction tools that allowed that
because
overdoses themselves did not go down
overdose deaths went down people were
able to reduce those deaths because the
availability of Narcan a variety of
different
um overdose harm reduction tools
fentanyl test strips are something that
we want to encourage people to use right
we want people to be able to have this
so that they do not die because there
was something that was in their drugs
that they did not know was there now we
don't really want to encourage use but
if someone is going to use if we are
dealing with reality uh what we could do
is we can reduce the harm on that person
providing things like this provide for
people to knowledgeably use substances
and it saves lives it has been proven
over and over I have studies I can send
you
to illustrate the idea of why this
particular drug paraphernalia in the
categories categorization of drug
paraphernalia and what the implications
are of having something like this as
under that heading I'd like to just
share a story a short story and like I
said I'm going to keep it brief
um my boys and I were driving across the
country we did this a whole lot when
they were little
um it's probably 10 or 11 years ago they
were still toddlers they were still in
booster seats and car seats we'll just
say that
um and we're driving across the country
we're going through Arkansas and there's
a lot of highway traffic and so I said
oh I'm just going to take this alternate
route we get off on this alternate route
and unfortunately apparently I was still
driving like I was on the highway so I
got pulled over I was speeding going
about 10 miles above the speed limit
well the officer pulls me over and uh
it's a veteran and he's training a
rookie and uh he comes over to my window
and he's kind of you know the passenger
side window and it's kind of leaning
over and talking to me through that
window
um you know we're talking about speeding
and where am I coming from I had
Massachusetts place at the time and here
I am in Arkansas
um and he mentions to me uh he says what
is that smell I said well I'm not sure
what that smell is because I'm driving
in a car with my toddlers say I don't
smoke in my car but I do smoke he says
well
um you know what what brand of
cigarettes do you smoke I said oh well
there's not really a brand I roll my own
you know and he's very curious about
that and I said here I have my setup uh
because you know when I take a break I
want to get out of the car I have my
whole setup over here to roll up a
cigarette right so I have a box of tubes
I have a big bag of tobacco and then I
have this crank machine where you just
kind of put the tube with the filter on
the end of it put the tobacco in boom
you crank it wonderful great little
machine handy dandy well he did not know
what that was and even though I was
explaining to him and I had the entire
set up there he decided that that was
drug paraphernalia
a tobacco rolling setup so because he
decided that that allowed him to be able
to search my car uh get my children and
I out of the car asked me to get out
pull out the car seats the booster seat
all that kind of stuff I'm sitting on
the side of basically some random route
in Arkansas humiliated out of my mind
for about 30 to 45 minutes because this
officer decided that this was drug
paraphernalia and because of that he was
able to steal my property he took my
property my rolling machine which is
wonderful because I have that because
I'm broke and it saves you money but
okay uh takes my property he pulls
everything out of my car we're on a six
to eight week road trip do you want to
know how much stuff was in my car there
was a lot pulls out the booster seats
all this kind of stuff me and my toddler
children on the side of the road of
course he's going through everything and
he's thinking that you know every every
little cigar box is going to be hit the
jackpot oh we're gonna find the weed
we're gonna find something no he found
nothing there was nothing in my car
because he considered this drug
paraphernalia it allowed him to take
possession of my property it allowed him
to to negate my civil liberties and
search my car and it allowed him to
humiliate me on the side of the road
this is a minor story
so and at the end of the day I have a
charge for drug paraphernalia position
because he decided that that was drug
paraphernalia so the importance of
identifying what is and what isn't drug
paraphernalia I find very important for
our civil liberties and to be able to
save lives in this situation as far as
we're talking about the overdose crisis
I'm going to
wrap it up there I do have the um I do
have the RSA that this is included in
I'll pass it around I have copies for
everyone so that you can see where this
fits into the control Drug Act and yeah
open any questions
representative Newman
could you just give a brief description
about what the test strips are like and
how they're used or cumbersome or or
that whole situation to the degree that
you think is necessary to clarify that
yeah they're pretty much I mean picture
a pregnancy test
it's very similar to that
there'll be no further questions thank
you very much thank you
the chair calls and
Nina Hanson Alina anina
good afternoon members of the committee
thanks for having me here uh I paused a
second there because uh representative
Newman I believe you asked about test
strips
I have some right here it's it's in a
little packet
um
it's used for urinalysis to test if
somebody has you know it'll show up in
your urine what drugs you're using if
you have the right panels to test for it
but you can use it to test your drugs by
taking a little bit of the powder and
mixing it with some water and and you
dip it in the same way so that's how
they are used so it is a it's a medical
tool basically it is a urinalysis device
that is used in a in a medical setting
in that way but can also be used
to see if if fentanyl pings on there
does that help
Mr can I say thank you for that
clarification it was absolutely confused
okay
if you would like to know more you know
I can leave them here for visual aid for
anybody who would like them but let us
move forward thank you so much everybody
my name is anina Hansen I'm a resident
of Peterborough I'm a person in recovery
from alcoholism and I support HB 287
because it eliminates the possibility
that anyone could face legal charges for
possession of a medical tool that helps
to keep people alive
there's someone else who would have
loved to be here today testifying in
favor of this bill and that's my life
partner Phil spaniola Phil was a New
Hampshire State Rep for Belknap County
who sat on the Health and Human Services
committee and he was in long-term
recovery from alcohol and heroin
addiction
my guy was Fearless about sharing his
story of substance addiction right up
until he wasn't
until his mental health issues untreated
during covid got the better of him and
he relapsed and a year and a half ago
died in a Manchester drug den of a
fentanyl overdose
if I could go back I would do anything
to get some fentanyl test strips in his
hands I would say honey while we figure
out how to get you the help you need
let's keep you safe
I know it seems counter-intuitive to
help people use illegal drugs safely
I thought so too last March eight months
after Phil's death I took a job at a
recovery Community organization and
that's where I first encountered
fentanyl test strips me a woman who lost
the man I thought I would grow old with
due to fentanyl poisoning I'm supposed
to help people see if their drugs have
fentanyl so they can keep using
but as I learned more I realized it
actually makes sense
the basic science of substance addiction
teaches that once someone is chemically
addicted to a drug the physiology of the
brain changes
because drugs mirror the pain ending
pleasure-inducing chemical response of
natural life-sustaining processes such
as eating
the brain can come to associate drugs
with survival in the same way
in addition to having served as a State
Rep Phil worked in recovery he owned two
sober houses there was no one better
educated than he on the dangers of
street drugs so why did he use because
his brain had been hijacked reprogrammed
to demand that he pick up heroin in
order to live the same way your brain
would demand usurface to breathe after
being underwater too long
logic leaves this is survival
of course the brain can be reminded oh
right I can stay alive without this drug
millions of people have recovered from
substance addiction
I'm six years sober and I'm living my
best life
but you know who cannot recover from
substance addiction
dead people
dead people have a zero percent recovery
success rate and that is why I have
fallen in love with fentanyl test strips
because each one represents a second
chance a precious person someone's
beloved getting another chance
to live their best life someday too
New Hampshire's drug overdose rates are
54 higher than the national average
addressing our state's drug problem is a
big issue and it shouldn't get bogged
down in tiny distractions it's a crime
to use drugs such as heroin cocaine or
meth all of which are now routinely
contaminated with fentanyl and
potentially lethal amounts
but it should not be a crime to try and
stay alive long enough to stop using
them
I just learned a few days ago when
representative Newell asked me to
testify today that fentanyl test strips
are legally classified as drug
paraphernalia and let me tell you that
was a real shock because now in my
professional capacity I carry them
around in my car by the box full
you mean to tell me I could be charged
with possessing drug paraphernalia
oh get out of here what a distraction
diverting our valuable law enforcement
resources away from the problem and the
solution
sidetracked by a technicality while our
actual drug problems continue unchecked
and they are big like I am not
minimizing that in any way and I so
appreciate the effort that law
enforcement makes and the the uphill
battle they are fighting and I just
think this is uh
a distracting issue
if my guy was alive he'd be here today
testifying in favor of this bill and the
irony is that if he had had fentanyl
test strips he could be alive
giving people who use drugs materials to
test their drugs is not about promoting
drug use or illegal Behavior it's about
keeping humans who are in trouble alive
until they can get help period
and let's never forget that the problem
isn't just out there
sometimes the people who would benefit
from fentanyl test strips are sitting
right here in these chairs
or have loved ones people
that are close to you who might be
struggling with this too
so I'm asking for Phil and for me and
for all the people with hijacked brains
and for all the people who love them
please support HB 287 and remove the
possibility that anyone could face
criminal charges for possession of test
strips so that we can keep our focus on
the real problems around drug use and
help our citizen live citizens live to
tell their recovery stories
thank you
open to questions there's anything
um no questions thank you very much for
your testimony
this time the chair will call Daniel
kopobia
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee I'm a representative
Popovich Miller I'm a freshman from
Windham and I really appreciate your
time I know how busy you are so I'm
gonna keep this as short as I can and
try not to repeat anything that you
already know like for example the fact
that
drug use is deadly even when the drugs
are pure but contaminated drugs are
deadlier and you know I think it
behooves us to do whatever we can to
decrease that damage at the end of the
day harm reduction is the right way to
look at the drug policy
right now the law is written includes
those two words that this bill is trying
to remove that include the testing and
analyzing equipment in drug
paraphernalia therefore providing an
incentive for people not to have them
which leads to worse outcomes and I
believe that the
the words were included at the time when
the bill was written because at the time
everybody thought that only drug dealers
would need those things we are in a
different world today where that those
types of devices medical devices are
available widely and you know we need to
cons reconsider the impact of that
policy removing the testing and
analyzing equipment would allow us to
still prosecute drug dealers look at the
remaining drug paraphernalia the
finishes it's extensive there is no drug
dealer that's just gonna have testing
and analyzing equipment it would not in
any way decrease the ability of our
justice system to prosecute and you know
put the drug dealers where they belong
but it would allow people who just have
the testing equipment whether it's for
themselves or you know people like we
just heard people who just try to help
others and provide services to people in
need not worry about you know criminally
being criminally prosecuted for allowing
to help
I
the law as written just removes the
definition of those two words removes it
from the law but frankly one could argue
and this is not the intent of this law
that
drug dealers who have testing and
equipment should receive a more
favorable outcome because they are
trying to you know do less harm but
again that's beyond the scope of this
law
I want to also remind everybody that
banning those devices by making their
position illegal is providing a
disincentive to people who research and
produce those devices if you know that
you cannot sell them in the state of New
Hampshire at least not legally less
money will be invested in life-saving
Technologies and drugs so
to sum up from the point of view of
Criminal Justice this bill does not in
any way decrease the ability to
prosecute drug dealers from the point of
view of Public Safety it will have a
clear positive impact by helping people
help themselves or help others and since
I didn't know at the time when I
co-sponsored the bill that I'm going to
end up on the finance committee but
that's where I ended up I can assure you
that any revenues that the state misses
are going to be tiny and the expenditure
is a Prosecuting people in these
situations are gonna greatly you know
basically it's going to have a positive
Financial impact to even though frankly
that shouldn't really be your
consideration but since it has an FN
designation you know that's something
that I wanted to bring up I really
appreciate your time and I'm available
for any questions thank you
thank you for your testimony
thank you
chair calls Carrie Nolte
thank you so much
um to the committee um I am Carrie Nolte
I'm an associate professor of nursing at
the University of New Hampshire where my
research focuses on harm reduction and
reducing drug related harms like
infection and overdose I'm also a family
nurse practitioner who practices in
healthcare for the homeless through van
based Outreach and I'm here speaking on
behalf of myself although with my
expertise is my background
I have submitted written testimony by
email to the committee including quite a
few links and education around drug
checking and the evidence for it
um and I just want to speak out in
support of House Bill 287
um as you know there is currently some
question as to whether fentanyl test
strips could be prosecuted but I would
also like to share a little bit about
comprehensive drug checking so we um and
call the committee's attention to House
Bill 470 which is also has been referred
to your committee and hopefully will be
heard at a later date
so fentanyl test strips are very
important in order to check the presence
of one substance fentanyl we anticipate
there also will be more rapid tests
available for other substances that are
being cut into the drug Supply
but in the meantime a best practice
around comprehensive drug checking has
been
developed and
um in my opinion House Bill 470 more
comprehensively allows this
um and so
um within comprehensive drug checking
these are usually using what what are
called ftir machines
um don't ask me the abbreviation uh in
order to get the specific substances one
substance we're seeing in clinical care
or we think we're seeing in clinical
care but we can't quantify it because we
don't have comprehensive drug checking
is something called xylazine xylazine is
a animal tranquilizer it's used in
veterinary medicine and we perceive that
based on the based on it being
identified in local States Massachusetts
and Rhode Island with similar
presentations it's present in New
Hampshire
some of it can cause different sedating
side effects than opiates it can cause a
decrease in heart rate but probably the
most prom dominant thing we're seeing
clinically is really really severe
wounds that are more like are are
infected but are also more consistent
with Burns there's almost like a
chemical burn component to using this so
as substances will be ever changing and
the drug Supply will become more and
more dangerous I think you see the
importance based on two bills being
brought to the house in this session on
drug checking and although I support
House Bill 287 I think that the
committee could take a deeper dive into
470 and consider that as a best practice
which has been used across other states
um one of the one of the concerns around
um so House Bill 287 will eliminate
testing and analyzing and that is
important for Rapid test strips like
fentanyl test strips but comprehensive
drug checking does go beyond that there
will be processing and preparing and
packaging and so those are some of the
things and I won't go into all of the
details but will be coming to the
committee to look at and I'm happy to
answer questions
thank you for your testimony
all right representative Newman do you
have a question I I just had a quick
question about 470s and you said it was
more comprehensive than this does it
move drug power yeah that representative
that's coming so we'll we'll address
that when it comes thank you
represent excuse me um Kate Faye
foreign
I'm sorry for my handwriting it's
actually Kate Bry I'm the vice president
of graduate I'm sure I'm sure it was my
handwriting I'll be very brief
um uh we do support new future I'm um
the vice president of advocacy
um at new Futures we support
evidence-based uh prevention treatment
and Recovery policies for health and
wellness and substance use disorder we
are in support of house bill
287. we stand with our colleagues who
have said it'd be great for the
committee to also take a deeper dive
into HB 470 since that's more
comprehensive
um so it won't go into long testimony
today but I will leave you with both a
CDC overview of functional test strips
um why they are effective harm reduction
strategy as well as a more detailed
article from Health Affairs outlining
why these strips Empower people and save
lives and so hopefully that will provide
you with background information as well
thank you for your testimony oh
representative
um
one of the things I know that your
organization
is is very selective with um
when it comes to supporting things like
legalization this isn't something that
you do lightly as we'll probably find
out during the Cannabis hearings
but the can you talk a little bit about
a harm reduction strategy and and and
where your organization is on that and
and how and what you think of that as an
overall way for sort of lessening the
the impact of the the issues we're
seeing with fentanyl and other opioids
now
so we are absolutely supportive of the
full Continuum of Care with substance
use disorder that means prevention
primary secondary tertiary uh treatment
and Recovery harm reduction is a key
piece of the puzzle
um and so a functional test strips along
with Narcan and the Good Samaritan law
all bills we supported and actually
helped write we are very
um uh behind harm reduction strategies
when we get into the Cannabis discussion
I think the issues we have has been
around a lack of
um principles around protecting children
in previous versions of the law we want
to be careful about not advertising and
marketing to them we want to be careful
about making sure we have potency limits
just like we do with alcohol so those
are basic prevention primary prevention
but we also support tertiary and
secondary prevention steps of which
functional chest strips are one
thank you
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Frank Knack from the
ACLU
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Frank canac I'm
the policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and we are here in strong
support of HB 287
um this really provides New Hampshire as
as you've heard with an opportunity to
build on its harm reduction successes
you know when naloxone was introduced
back in 2015
um
by 2017 we had seen the peak in the
current peak in overdose deaths at 490
and uh we had you know more recently the
New Hampshire drug monitoring initiative
which is part of the Department of
Health and Human Services uh quote state
that naloxone very likely contributed to
it both a decline in overdose deaths and
the EMS provided Narcan Administration
through 2019 and then if you look at
just 20 uh November 21 through October
22 that one year period
um uh the the administration of naloxone
by EMS saved 865 lives and so the the
Embrace of harm reduction strategies by
New Hampshire is having a huge positive
impact at saving lives and the um this
legislation is the next step in ensuring
that we have a harm reduction
a number of harm reduction tools that
continue to save lives
and so I want to touch on two myths
around around funnel test strips that
may come up um having so far
one is that they're used to test the
purity of the substance and that's just
not true it's like a Cova test strip it
just tests whether the substance is in
there or not and so the notion that you
know people are using it to test the
drug Purity is is just not true it's not
how they function and the second is that
they encourage drug use and for this I
want to just quote the director of the
office of National Drug control policy
who said quote there is no scientific
evidence to support this notion that
harm reduction services like fentanyl
test strip somehow encourage drug use
but there is significant evidence to
support the fact that these tools can
save lives and so this is coming from
the head of the office of national
control drug control policies in
addition you have major governmental
non-governmental medical and public
health organizations all stating that we
should have these harm reduction tools
available including the CDC the
Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services Administration and the American
Medical Association and finally 24
States
um have legalized both The Possession
and distribution of fentanyl test strips
including our neighbors in Vermont Maine
and Massachusetts and in just the period
between August 1 2021 and August 31 2022
so just that 13-month recent period we
saw 10 States move in this direction
including deep red States like Alabama
Tennessee and
um Louisiana and so this is again
another harm reduction option that we
have that we should embrace and happy to
answer any questions
so representative Bolden
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um is there any evidence that the use of
a fentanyl test strip might discourage
drug use in that it may identify an
unwanted
substance that wasn't what someone
thought they were purchasing
um but what I can say is there is six
significant evidence through
peer-reviewed studies that show that
when people use fentanyl test strips
that there's a much greater likelihood
that they will ensure that they're using
with someone else who could call 9-1-1
or administer Narcan if they have an
overdose that they'll use less of the
drug if it tests positive for Fentanyl
and so again these are documented
documented findings that show that these
are significant harm reduction tool that
should be available
thank you for your testimony thank you
it's time to chair calls representative
Christine Siebert
hi thank you for hearing me today
um my name is Christine Siebert I'm from
Ward one in Manchester
um District 21.
and I'll make this brief because a lot
of people already hit on a lot of the
points and they did a great job
um but I just wanted to bring up they
are a harm reduction tool
um the big one I want to mention is they
do not assist in the use of drugs so
they are not used as a tool Within
actual the drug use itself
um and we obviously have a really big
problem in Manchester
our services are overwhelmed our
response the EMS fire everyone they also
have to send everyone out
when anything happens there's also
people that overdose multiple times and
this also you know contributes to the
fatigue that you hear many First
Responders speak of
and so this is and when I was canvassing
for my for running for office this last
time this past summer this was something
a lot of people brought up
so this would be and a lot of it is
about the money and the services that a
lot of this costs so I just believe
overall this is a great tool
and I understand maybe someone
originally did this with some hopefully
good intentions but the pro problems
become overwhelming and it's become
overwhelming across the entire country
so
I hope you will vote in support of this
bill
thank you so much
thank you very much
this time the chair calls Lauren
McKinley
hi my name is Lauren McGinley I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
harm reduction Coalition I wanted to
take just a few moments to say
um
it I'll go so far as to say that New
Hampshire harm reduction Coalition is
probably the state's largest distributor
of fentanyl test strips we've been
utilizing them since April of 2021 when
the CDC and samsa issued a co-request to
funded entities to begin using them to
prevent fatal overdoses due to fentanyl
contamination in all substances
so it's important to think when we think
fentanyl we generally think a
contaminant in heroin
fentanyl can be a contaminant and is
currently being seen as a contaminant in
a lot of substances that people are not
familiar with the presence of fentanyl
or in how to react to a potential
fentanyl or opioid induced overdose
so if you casually use say cocaine on
the weekends as many college students
typically will start to experiment with
you would not have the proper tools on
hand to address a an opioid induced
overdose because cocaine users stimulant
users are not typically aware of how to
to react to an overdose like that so
fentanyl test strips serve a really
important tool with people who use drugs
to identify not only what is in their
drug Supply so the presence of fentanyl
is a yes or no that these fentanyl test
strips can provide nothing further than
that but also where fentanyl is starting
to be seen including in stimulants like
cocaine and methamphetamines
um as the largest distributor of
fentanyl test strips I just want to call
to um
the committee's attention that Federal
resources are completely able to be
applied to the purchase of fentanyl test
strips and have been able to to been
utilized since April of 2021. we have an
incredibly large surplus of fentanyl
test strips and have made the offer to
supply them to whichever organization
feels like they would benefit from
having them additionally I would be
happy to answer any questions if people
have questions relative to how a person
who uses drugs utilizes fentanyl test
strips or what some of the anecdotal
responses have been having them as a
supply at our harm reduction events
that's it I have a question are are
people able to just do you have a
location where people are able to come
in and obtain these yes yep absolutely
so we make ourselves present in in many
different ways and we've had people
reach out to us via social media we've
had people show up at some of our harm
reduction events or syringe service
programs we also have the ability to
connect them to a regional care
coordinator who can help them procure
the test strips but then also review
with them quickly how to use it
appropriately to interpret the results
and if if this bill were passed and to
become law do you have the
infrastructure to to get these out into
the community
um in a more in a broader broader way
quickly yes absolutely we already have
practice with that um we are currently a
covered entity that is allowed to
distribute fentanyl test strips because
they are included in the SSP law in the
state of New Hampshire
um as any tools that are used to prevent
overdoses
representative Bolden
thank you
your testimony sure you're saying that
um
the distribution of test of fentanyl
test strips is currently federally
funded and that also under current law
someone who obtains that
through federal funds could be charged
with possession of paraphernalia
uh great question and it is slightly
confusing so the list of entities in the
state of New Hampshire that can safely
distribute fentanyl test strips is very
small I know that my organization is
protected under the SSP law in the state
of New Hampshire because I can
distribute a list of supplies syringes
safe injection equipment Narcan naloxone
and any other device that may prevent
harms occurring from the use of
substances
there are many places that are not
protected but
are able to distribute them if they feel
like the legal risk is
to to be clear though whoever you give
it to would be in violation once they
possess it I don't believe so actually I
think that the onus is on the
Distributing entity and once they are
received by individuals
um that there is not a legal risk there
I am not a lawyer though we do
there is one here okay represent Bolden
do you have a follow-up
oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to steal that
so to be clear if I go to the new
shelter on Maple Street in Manchester
um where they have test strips available
and I take some and I have them on me
and I've stopped could I be charged with
possession and similarly if I were to
say give one to the guy that camps at
the Hanford by my house like I did
recently could he be charged with
possession of paraphernalia this is a
great question and one that we've been
struggling with in the state since
um Samson the CDC requested that
programs start Distributing them in this
way
and I don't have a great answer for you
um
I'm sorry I think it kind of highlights
the need for the clarification of
language like this because
um I think it was said best it is such a
distracting technicality to be held up
on when such important work can be done
with the utilization of this and many
other tools
your test morning
um is there anyone else who wishes to
testify about this who has not handed in
a pink card until the last second
um now unless you're an attorney
um I'd rather not
thank you
thank you Mr chair oh did you call me
officially I
The Honorable representative
thank you Mr chair I didn't get your
card yet so there it is
uh and thank you honorable members of
the committee
um for the record my name is Ellen Reed
and I represent Newmarket and new fields
and I hesitated to put my card in
because I don't think there's too much
that I can add but there were a couple
small things that I thought I could add
first I want to clarify the answer that
I just received it's the members of
those organizations that may have some
legal protection so if you have joined
one of those organizations and you're
officially a member then you might have
in court after a police officer has
charged you with paraphernalia and you
go through that process you might have
some legal protection there
however so I cannot speak as other
people have as a person who uses any
drugs I actually developed an
intolerance to marijuana when I was in
my 20s and I have a commercial driver's
license so I I can't I don't have a dog
in the race in that sense and I'm not an
expert like the other people but I am a
lawmaker as you all are and I can say in
my opinion as a lawmaker this should
have never been put into this law
um
the Ridiculousness of the idea of
testing and analyzing equipment being
put into the paraphernalia law I think
is made clear by the fact that you just
witnessed a crime from an earlier
speaker who showed you paraphernalia
I don't think anybody in this room
thinks that she should should be
arrested
um I think that these words were put
into law in a punitive sense
um at a time where it was more common
although we haven't gotten rid of stigma
it was more common to think of drug
users in a stigmatized way that they
have an inherent moral feeling instead
of the Way That We Now understand them
to have a health condition
and we know that we cannot penalize
people out of mental health or substance
abuse conditions
um I think we all know unquestionably
that the State and the country are
tending towards legalization of
different substances anyway but I think
of the purpose the original purpose of
these laws was originally to help people
not use drugs then we should not in fact
be punishing people who are just trying
to survive their condition and the last
thing I'll say as a lawmaker since I
know that you have another bill that's
similar but more complicated
One path forward maybe to pass this so
that you have at least something through
the simpler thing and retain the other
more complex Bill you'll probably want
to get into more detail over the the
fall and then you have either a second
bite at the Apple or another piece of
legislation if you want to get into more
details but that is my opinion as a
lawmaker thank you very much for your
time I can't imagine anybody has
questions but I'm here for them
uh representative wheeler thank you
representative Reed for taking my
question and thank you Mr chairman for
letting me uh ask it
um my question was for representative
Newell but I'm wondering if you'd be
able to answer it seeing as though you
had your last sentence there um there is
HP 470 on the docket here and I'm just
wondering why this legislation came
representative I I don't mean to
interrupt you but are you a co-sponsor
on this bill am I not allowed no you're
not we're not alone my apologies I
didn't know that's why I shattered my
hands for the last bill but she heard it
so if she wants to go ahead and answer
that's okay
um I think the new house rule that I
helped get through is that everyone is
entitled uh to either participate from
one or the other side regardless of
condition of co-sponsorship however
having said that yes I would I would say
that I think a prudent way forward to
make sure that this committee has the
ability to pass this either this this
concept either this year or next year
depending on whether or not the Senate
goes for this year's version is to pass
one and retain one and since the other
one that you have before you is the more
complex one it makes sense that that's
the one retained this is very simple
elegant language I think just strikes
two words and I think it makes sense to
go ahead and get it in the sentence
hands sooner rather than later
thank you
at this time I'm going to ask there's a
captain here from the state police if
you could come up and just elucidate a
little bit on the legality of possession
currently as the law states
chairman uh yes just uh so to to kind of
address the the overall question I guess
by the
um the technicality of it could somebody
technically be in violation of
possessing drug paraphernalia it seems
like that that probably could be but I
am not aware of any
um of any current cases like this
um in that situation where you know
fentanyl test strips have been charged
as drug paraphernalia or anything like
that I do understand that the intention
of the bill is to you know support the
harm reduction
um you know tools that we already have
in place
um as from the state police perspective
I wasn't going to take a position on
this bill one way or another my
intention was to monitor it to see if
there were potentially any unintended
consequences
um with taking that language out at the
moment I don't see any but I'm also not
an attorney I'm not well versed in uh
you know in a lot of the the legal
aspects of these things but by the
letter of the law that it somebody could
potentially be be charged
um but by like I say I'm not aware of
any cases
um of that happening at the moment
so just to put a fine point on it
currently there is legal liability
exposure
um regardless of whether or not it's
being charged it's still out there in my
in my opinion I think that that there
could be
um
but I also was not aware of the people
that are Distributing it
um so that is new to me
um and you know their protections that
they have with it coming from from
federal funding and things like that I
was not aware of that but I also you
know I'm not aware of any cases where
this has been an issue
thank you does anyone have any questions
go ahead
so also to put a finer Point thank you
bye-bye thanks for taking my question
you're saying that you don't see any and
I know that you're speaking sort of um
casually because you haven't had a ton
of time to prepare but you're saying
that you don't see any potential
negative consequences of the basically
passing this bill is written I mean I I
read the bill as it as it's written
um thinking outside the trying to think
outside the box to see if there were
potentially any unintended consequences
from what the Bill's intention was at
the moment I personally do not don't see
any
um
but I'll just leave it at that if I can
yeah
thank you very much for um stepping up
um
you have a you you wanted to say
something
yeah sure just go ahead and read it so
everyone can take it down if you want to
take a note
again Frank Eco of New Hampshire
um so under
RSA 318b263
um it says A person shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor who dot dot dot delivers
possesses with the intent to deliver any
drug paraphernalia
and so under the definition of drug
paraphernalia New Hampshire testing
falls under that so it's a unclassified
misdemeanor to distribute so it'd be
like the harm reduction Coalition is
protected but if I gave it to someone
else
um who would benefit from it I would be
liable
is it your understanding that anyone
they give it to is protected or only
they as a distributor are protected so
under the current law possession is
protected but if someone gives it to
someone else that's distribution not
protected very good thank you very much
I appreciate it
is there anyone else wishing to testify
who has not already testified
there being none I will go ahead and
close the public hearing
that concludes our business for today if
anyone has any questions please come up
and see me afterwards please make note
of your subcommittee assignment
and I will see you all
tomorrow tomorrow
foreign